YUFENG GUO: Hey, did you
know that TensorFlow now
supports JavaScript?
Well, if you didn't, now you do.
Stay tuned to find out
how to run TensorFlow
on the most widely
used programming
language in the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BEEPING]
Welcome to Cloud AI
Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode,
we'll unpack
TensorFlow.js a little bit
and show you some of the amazing
things that you can do with it.
I'm sure you'll come up
with your own epic use cases
by the end of this.
So let's dive right in.
TensorFlow.js lives
at js.tensorflow.org.
There you can find all the
documentation, tutorials,
and links to awesome examples.
The tutorials really
do a great job
of layering on
top of each other,
building up your
TensorFlow.js skills.
Start at the top of the page and
work your way down one by one.
Along the way, you'll train a
convolutional neural network
in your browser and
create a Pac-Man game.
Now, you can play with data
you record with your webcam.
So what else have people
made with TensorFlow.js?
Well, for one,
there's PoseNet, which
does a pretty impressive
job at identifying
your position in an image.
OK, so that silliness
aside, what else
is TensorFlow.js good for?
Well, you can import your
TensorFlow and Keras models
directly into the browser now.
This enables you to train
complex models with large data
sets--
just like you're used to doing--
and then bring those models
straight into the browser.
And we'll actually
see an example
of that in a future
episode of AI Adventures.
So keep your eye out.
Now, if you really
want to get fancy,
you can take an imported
model in TensorFlow.js
and then further train it.
So imagine loading in an
existing state of the art
research model, then adding
some of your own training data
to specialize that
model in some way,
maybe with images
from the webcam.
So some of you may
be wondering, hey,
what's the relationship
between TensorFlow.js
and this other
library, deeplearn.js?
Well, TensorFlow.js is a whole
ecosystem of JavaScript tools
for machine learning.
And it actually evolved
from deeplearn.js.
That portion is now known
as TensorFlow.js Core.
The rest of
TensorFlow.js features
additional
functionality and tools
to help make doing machine
learning in JavaScript easier.
Another big question around
doing machine learning
with JavaScript is performance.
Anecdotally, for predictions,
TensorFlow.js with WebGL
is about one and half
to two times slower
than TensorFlow using
Python with AVX enabled.
On the training side, we've
seen that large models train
actually 10 or even 15
times slower in a browser
compared with
TensorFlow on Python.
So while it's unlikely that
TensorFlow.js will completely
replace the raw performance
of server side training,
there are some
amazing experiences
to be created via client
side machine learning.
This was just the quick
overview of TensorFlow.js.
I was super excited at the fact
that this is out in the wild.
So I really needed
to get this to you
so you can get started
as soon as possible.
We'll spend some more
time with TensorFlow.js
in future episodes
and look at some tips
and tricks in more detail.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
And if you enjoyed it,
please hit that Like button
and subscribe to get all
the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, head on over to
js.tensorflow.org and get
started today.